Speaker 1: While we were on vacation, Fox
News host Tucker Carlson made the baseless
claim, at least as far as he's presented evidence
that the NSA, the National Security Agency,
had been spying on him.
And then the story disappeared for a little
bit until yesterday.
Tucker appeared on the Fox Business program
Mornings with Maria, hosted by the notorious
Trump brownnoser Maria Bartiromo.
Tucker is now saying that he recently learned
that it will soon come out, that not only
has the NSA been spying on him, but the NSA
leaked the contents of his emails to journalists
in an effort to discredit him in relation
to, I guess, seeking an interview with Vladimir
Putin.
Now, he says it's not a figment of his imagination,
that it is very, very real.
So let's look at this interview that he had
with Maria Bartiromo.
And these are very serious allegations.
So let's listen to it.
Speaker 2: The NSA spying.
Tucker Carlson tonight, host Tucker Carlson
said last week on his program that he has
information from a whistleblower showing that
the NSA is spying on him and planning to leak
sensitive communications to get his show canceled.
Tucker joins us right now.
Tucker, it's great to have you this morning.
Thank you so much for being here.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah.
You are the only people I get up for.
Maria, it's an honor to be here.
Yeah, it's you don't go on TV.
They likely to say the government is spying
on me because you sound like a crazy person.
And of course, you would never say that unless
you knew that it was true.
And I did know that it was true almost accidentally.
I was in Washington for a funeral last week
and ran into someone I know.
Well said I have a message for you and then
proceeded to repeat back to me details from
emails and texts that I sent and had told
no one else about.
So it was verified in this person said, look,
you
Speaker 1: know, now what's important to understand
here is this is Tucker's assertion.
And we have to be able to distinguish between
if what Tucker is saying is true, then X,
Y, Z versus simply Tucker is making this assertion
and as yet has not presented any evidence
for it.
Now, the first thing to understand is just
because we would be skeptical of this claim,
because there's not yet been evidence presented
doesn't mean that we think the NSA is great
or always acts appropriately.
And this is a really important thing in the
Trump era.
Often when if you're on the left and you say,
hey, you know what, there's really no reason
to doubt the FBI when the FBI said X or there's
really no reason to doubt the CIA.
When the CIA said why, sometimes right wingers
and even sometimes leftists will say, oh,
what now you love the CIA, which did all this
bad stuff globally for decades?
No, no, no.
We're just looking at these claims.
The NSA does spy on people.
That's what they do.
The NSA could leak stuff, but Tucker has not
yet presented evidence and maybe he will.
So we're not laughing this off if the NSA
is spying on Tucker.
And leaking his emails, I want to know, but
as you will see here, he's not yet presenting
any evidence.
Let's look at a little bit more of this.
Speaker 3: It has this and that was proven
by the person repeating back the contents
of the email and is going to use it against
you.
Now, to be totally blunt with you, I would
never have said this in public if it was something
I felt was wrong or illegal or immoral.
They don't actually have anything on me, but
they do have my email.
So I knew they were spying on me.
And again, to be totally blunt with you, as
a defensive move, I thought I better say this
out loud, because I have no I have no other
way to defend myself.
I'm just an American citizen.
I don't have any position of official authority,
but I do have a megaphone.
Speaker 1: Right.
He does have a megaphone.
It's a little bit I mean, listen, when you
have one of the top rated shows on one of
the three major cable networks to say you're
No.
One special, essentially, is what he's saying.
It's not exactly representative of the spirit
of Tucker's privileged position.
But let's not harp on that too much.
Say this
Speaker 3: out loud.
And I did.
And the NSA didn't deny it then yesterday,
OK, I learned that and this is going to come
out soon, that the NSA.
Leaked the contents of my email to journalists
in an effort to discredit me, I know because
I got a call from one of them saying, oh,
this is what your email was about.
So it is not in any way a figment of my imagination.
It's confirmed.
It's true.
They're not allowed to spy on American citizens.
They are.
Speaker 1: OK, so there's a there's a ton
of stuff there.
Now, Tucker says the NSA didn't deny a part
of this.
Let's look at what the NSA actually said,
because I think it's important to actually
see the wording.
The NSA put out a statement saying on June
twenty eighth, twenty twenty one, Tucker Carlson
alleged that the NSA has been, quote, monitoring
our communications and is planning to leak
them in an attempt to take this show off the
air.
This allegation is untrue.
Tucker Carlson has never been an intelligence
target of the agency and the NSA has never
had any plans to try to take his program off
the air.
NSA has a foreign intelligence mission.
We target foreign powers to generate insights
on foreign activities that could harm the
United States.
With limited exceptions, like an emergency,
the NSA may not target a U.S. citizen without
a court order that explicitly authorizes the
targeting.
Now, what what Tucker is focusing in on there
is that the NSA doesn't deny reading his emails.
Now, it is possible and this, you know, with
all of the Trump people, American Trump people
that were in contact with Russians when the
Russians were being surveilled, which we could
say we don't like that this is what the NSA
does.
But the NSA has a foreign intelligence mission.
When the NSA was monitoring Russians, when
Trump people communicated with the Russians,
incidentally, they observed the communications
of the Americans who were in touch with the
Russians.
Right.
So, Tucker, then last night talked in more
detail about what this is all about.
What if you listen to it, it could explain
some of this, OK, and then we'll talk about
whether it's OK, I guess, God,
Speaker 3: we're happy to report that late
this spring I contacted a couple of people
I thought could help get us an interview with
Russian President Vladimir Putin.
Yeah, I told nobody I was doing this other
than my executive producer, Justin Wells.
I wasn't embarrassed about trying to interview
Putin.
He's obviously newsworthy.
You're American citizen.
I can interview anyone I want absolutely to.
But still, in this case, I decided to keep
it quiet.
I figured that any kind of publicity would
rattle the Russians and make the interview
less likely to happen.
But the Biden administration found out anyway.
By reading my emails, I learned from a whistleblower
at the NSA plan to leak the contents.
Speaker 1: So first of all, it's important
that when when you say the Biden administration
to you know, that that's questionable language
for this.
If you understand how, you know, Trump was
constantly criticizing the FBI for things
that did during his administration.
If you apply this logic, that was the Trump
administration.
Right.
If any action taken by FBI, CIA or NSA during
a presidency is that presidency, that administration
doing it, then it was the Trump administration
that did all the things that Trump criticized
the FBI for.
I think that's pretty dubious emails
Speaker 3: to media outlets.
Why would they do that?
Well, the point, of course, was to paint me
as a disloyal American.
A Russian operative been called that before,
a stooge of the Kremlin, a traitor doing the
bidding of a foreign adversary.
And, of course, I mean, hardly the only person
who has been accused of those things.
Speaker 1: So, OK, so so let's let's talk
about what's going on here now that we have
the full picture.
Many of these allegations are just unproven.
OK, the leaks by the NSA to journalists, all
it's if there's evidence of that, then I want
to see it.
I want to know what the NSA is doing.
I don't think the NSA is uniquely good or
bad.
American intelligence agencies sometimes do
good things.
Sometimes they do bad things.
Sometimes it's not easy to call something
good or bad.
If Tucker Carlson was in touch with people,
he may or may not have known.
Ah, Kremlin agents, Russian intelligence,
who who knows who Tucker was in touch with
in order to try to get an interview with Vladimir
Putin.
If those people were being monitored by the
NSA, then certainly by being in touch with
them, Tucker's communications would it would
have ended up monitored by the NSA.
This is not hugely shocking or controversial.
If you're talking to someone who's under surveillance,
like a foreign intelligence target, then by
talking to them, you're going to be surveilled.
We can debate that's good or bad, but it's
not shocking.
So no one is Tucker going to present proof.
We'll have to wait and see.
Number two, where was Tucker on this stuff
for years when it was happening already?
Now, all of a sudden that he believes or is
at least claiming it's happening to him?
It's his number one issue.
So there's a lot of stuff here to clear up.
But I want to be really clear if what Tucker
is saying is true, I want to know about it.
But it wouldn't be shocking that if Tucker
is talking to people, foreign agents being
surveilled by American intelligence, it would
be logical that his side of the communication
is also going to be subject to that surveillance,
not defending it, but it's exactly what you
would expect.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll have more of this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.